Die zwei Sprechstunden.
6 7 8 5 4 3 2 1.
Das Krasse ist, dass nach der gängigen Lesart der Staat sich das ja sogar rausnimmt. Der meint ja, dass er auf dein Computer rumschnüffeln möchte, weil du das schon vorher verschlüsselst. Jetzt stell dir mal vor, du fängst da schon an, während du mit deinem Hörgerät, mit irgend jemandem auf der anderen Seite eine verschlüsselte Kommunikation veranstaltest. Dann will der nach dieser Lesart auch auf dein Hörgerät, auf dein Implantat drauf, um dann voller Verschlüsselung schon abzunehmen, was du da gedacht hast.
Oder wenn du ein Exoskelett hast, dann läuft dich das zur Polizeiwache. Dann stell mal vor, also ich meine, Exoskelette, also der Unterschied zwischen Endoprothese und Exoprothese ist, glaube ich, klar. Endo ist innen drin, also irgendwo eingebaut. Kniegelenken, Sprunggelenken, sonst irgendwas. Und Exo ist, wenn man es außen ran baut, eben wie der Arm, von dem wir vorhin sprachen. Und so, jetzt gibt es ja auch Exoskelette, also zum Beispiel ein komplettes Gestell, wo sich jemand Gehbehindert ist, der jetzt nicht völlig behindert ist, sondern der seine Beine nur eben schlecht bewegen kann oder auch nicht mehr genug Kraft hat und so weiter, sich da reinstellt, reingurtet und dann damit losläuft. Das wird entwickelt von diversen Firmen, Japan, China und so weiter, auch von amerikanischen Militärs, damit Soldaten eben irre weit laufen können und gigantische Lasten heben. Also 100 Kilo hochheben mit so einem Ding geht. Verstärkt einfach nur ähnlich wie ein Elektrofahrrad, deine Kraft um den Faktor 3, sagen wir mal. Und jetzt stellen wir uns vor, was passiert, wenn so ein Ding einen Bug hat. Oder wir stellen uns vor, was passiert, wenn das ein Virus hat und jemand sozusagen ein Stück Software abspielen lässt, mit dir in diesem Gestell drin.
Was es schon klar sagt, ist, wenn die Technik so nah an unseren Körper heranrückt, also an ihn, uns oder direkt an uns rückt, ist natürlich die ganze Frage der Software-Sicherheit und der Integrität der informationstechnischen Systeme, die wir da haben, wird dabei natürlich nochmal deutlich akuter. Und die interessante Frage ist in der Tat, sind wir denn wirklich villens gerade vernetzte Implantate oder Explantate, die also auch Schnittstellen zum Netz haben und zum Beispiel mit Informationen arbeiten, die von außen kommen, trauen wir uns denn schon wirklich, die in Positionen zu bringen, wo man den Körper damit beschädigen kann? Und die Antwort darauf ist natürlich, naja, wir werden es wahrscheinlich machen, obwohl wir es eigentlich besser nicht machen sollten.
Wir sehen es doch gerade schon an unseren Mobiltelefonen. Das ist ja eine Wanze, die wir freiwillig mit uns mit rumtragen, die die ganze Zeit unsere Informationen, zumindest unsere Positionen beim Provider lässt.
Aber es ist doch deine Schnittstelle in das Kollektiv, bewusst sein der Cyborg-Gesellschaft.
Es ist verdammt nützlich natürlich, aber trotzdem ist die Abwägung, die wir da getrieben haben, scheinbar schon deutlich in die Richtung, dass wir das in Kauf nehmen.
Ich würde aber jetzt bevor wir so sagen und die ganz theoretischen Ausflüchtungen verflüchten, noch mal fragen wollen, wie das mit konkreten Angriffen ist. Ich habe nämlich jetzt noch im Hinterkopf, dass ich irgendwann mal gelesen zu haben, dass ich weiß nicht, ob es Herzschrittmacher waren oder Insulin-Depote.
Es gibt mehrere Geschichten. Zum einen gab es Insulinpumpen, die ein Bluetooth-Interface haben und wo übers Mobiltelefon der Insulinstatus gemessen und übertragen und mit dem Krankenhaus gesynkt wird. Es gibt EKG-Geräte, die mit einem zentralen Server reden und wo aus der Ferne quasi ein eingebordter Defibrillator ausgelöst werden kann, wenn EKG-Scheiße aussieht.
Hatte der Busch sowas nicht?
Angeblich ja. Es war ein bisschen unklar, ob es die Fernsteuerung für ihn war oder das EKG-Scheiße war. Das war alles ein bisschen unklar. Und da gab es dann tatsächlich genau diesen Fall, also bei diesen ferngestellten EKG-Defibrillator-Geräten, der Server, auf dem diese Anwendung lief, mit dem die Geräte kommuniziert haben, der war halt in so einer Amazon-Cloud. Und dann fiel halt das Amazon-Data-Center runter, weil sie da so ein fundamentales Problem gelaufen sind. Und dann waren die Patienten da halt ohne entsprechende Absicherung beziehungsweise Monitoring.
Na, solange das Ding jetzt nicht den Defibrillator auslöst, mal ein Fass.
Also bei den Insulinpumpen ist das tatsächlich möglich. Es ist ja so, dass tatsächlich Leute gemacht haben, die selber betroffen sind, also die selber diese Pumpen hatten. Die haben die halt gehackt und haben halt festgestellt, dass es total trivial ist, wäre sich da selber mit umzubringen, indem sie halt einfach diesen Insulinpump auf Dauerfluss stellen.
Darbe Hilfe.
Und das ist tatsächlich ein Problem, was zunehmend ernster wird. Und wo also auch die Richtlinien für digitale Medizintechnik sind, dem momentan überhaupt noch nicht gewachsen.
Ja, aber du kannst ja jeden Herzschrittmacher mit geeigneten Magnetfeldern schon aus der Spur bringen.
Du kannst auch jedes Herz mit geeigneten Magnetfeldern aus der Spur bringen. Also am Ende ist es natürlich irgendwie der Körperverletzung, wenn du da irgendwie mit was draufhältst.
Ja, bloß der Punkt ist halt, wenn es halt, diese Dinger werden halt alle in der Hand angeschlossen sein. Also ist halt vollkommen klar, dass das Kommunikationsmedium über diese Prothesen, Exoprothesen, was auch immer kommunizieren wird, das Internet sein. Und wenn die Software darauf so scheiße ist, wie der Rest auf diesem Planeten, dann muss man sich schon ernsthaft überlegen, wie groß ist dann das Risiko tatsächlich, dass man sich da irgendwie in den Wurm fängt, irgendwie auf seiner Beinprothese oder irgendwie so. Was auch immer man da halt irgendwie gerade hat.
Das eröffnet auch Chancen, dass der Hersteller dann ein Abo verkaufen kann. Und wenn man dann mal nicht bezahlt, dann geht's halt nicht mehr.
Das sieht ja schön aus.
Oder wenn du nach Polen laufen willst.
Dennis, noch letzte Frage an dich. Würdest du dir trotzdem so Dinge einbauen lassen oder lieber nicht?
Und wenn ja, was?
Genau. Ich möchte jetzt keine Werbung machen, aber ich finde so eine Werbung von früher ganz cool. Da geht der Kopf auf, so eine Zeitschrift geht rein, takt birnen zu. Ich sag mal so eine Wikipedia vielleicht für den Kopf, aber mehr auch nicht. Vielleicht Altersverschleißer oder so, wenn man irgendwas an der Hüfte hat. Aber ich sag mal, da bin ich noch ein bisschen zu old school, um zu sagen, da steh ich zu sehr aufs Seilbock. Also nee, nee. Wobei ich mir auch noch den zweiten Gedanken gemacht hab, wie wäre das denn mit Wettkämpfen? Also wenn der Mensch tatsächlich dann halt hinterher so ausgestattet wäre, wie würde der Wettkampf heißen? Quad-Core-Prozess.
Eben dummerweise nicht beim Auto-Rennen. Ich meine, Formel 1 ist ja deswegen so langweilig, weil da noch Leute drin sitzen und sie die Engineers nicht machen lassen, wie sie wollen.
Die Frage ist, wenn es Wettkämpfe gibt, es gab ja mal ein Behinderten, der wurde disqualifiziert, weil er diese Prothesen getragen hat, wovon ihr vorhin gesprochen hattet. Wo hört das auf und wo fängt das an? Was heißt das hinterher? Heißt das dann hinterher nicht bis zu 80 Kilo Kampfklasse, sondern Quad-Core gegen einen anderen Prozessor?
Da wird es auf jeden Fall interessant.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist eher eine theoretische Situation, wo es dann möglicherweise um Wettkampfregelments geht. Aber die spannende Frage ist ja, ob das auch auf die Gesellschaft auswirken kann. Ob es irgendwann normal ist, jeder muss eine Prothese tragen, weil es halt total normal angesehen wird, dass man 80 Kilo heben kann und halt total gut hört.
Und wenn du 75 bist, dann musst du aber noch laufen können. Oder banal schon mal, wenn du das und das Implantat nicht hast, kommst du da und da nicht rein. Das wäre so mal so ein ganz trivialer Ansatz, dass du nur, wenn du dich über ein Implantat identifizieren lässt.
Ohne ihre Steueridentifikationsnummer.
Genau, kommst du einfach da in das Amt nähren.
Das wär doch überhaupt auch mal eine schöne Idee, oder? Nachdem wir jetzt alle Pässe schon mal Biometrie gesehen haben. Gibt es so eine Überlegung schon? Auf die Schädelplatte draufplanken oder so?
Na ja, die Fußfessel bei den digitalen Gefangenen, das ist ja im Prinzip schon so.
Da geht es gerade momentan noch umgekehrt, nämlich indem man die DNA als Identifikationsmerkmal benutzt.
Ich glaube, da war auch ein Club, der hat gesagt, irgendwie hier Erfurt implantieren.
Ja, das war aber Bullshit. Also das war tatsächlich ein Fake.
Mit den ganzen Kühen machen sie das schon.
Also die haben halt, was die getan haben, die haben tatsächlich einen Rinder-Tech genommen, also mit dem halt identifiziert werden und haben es als Eintritts für ihre Disco genommen. Und ein paar doofe Hipster haben es tatsächlich gemacht, dass sie sich so ein Ding haben in die Schulter schieben lassen. Und dann stellte sich halt irgendwie ganz schnell raus, dass man diese Text, weil es halt so eine billig Text waren, die wirklich für Vieh-Identifikation gedacht waren, problemlos klonen konnte und man sich dann halt auch nicht so was in die Schulter schieben musste, sondern einfach irgendwie eine kleine Karte, wo halt ein indischer Tag mit der Information drauf war. Benutzt hat, um da reinzukommen. Und dann haben sie es auch ganz schnell wieder abgestellt, aber irgendwie so 30 oder 35 Trottel hatten es dann doch irgendwie sich irgendwie reinschieben lassen.
Ja nun, aber die machen sie auch Pissings wohin.
Okay, auch ein anderes Chaosradio würde ich sagen. Körperschmuck. Dennis, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Jo, ich wünsche euch einen schönen Abend, allen Zuhörern auch und liebe Grüße an das ganze Team.
Danke, danke.
So, und dann kommen wir jetzt zu der Stelle, wo wir sagen, okay, es gibt diese ganzen Technologien und die Überlegung, dass man das möglicherweise mal also einbauen kann oder möglicherweise nur anschrauben, je nachdem, ob ENDO oder EXO, aber dass wir auch heute schon Technologien benutzen, die im Prinzip unsere Sinne und möglicherweise auch unser Wesen erweitern. Wir hatten vorhin schon kurz mit Robin gesprochen. Robin ist blind und hat erzählt, er nutzt sein Handy, sein iPhone, um irgendwie Dinge auf den Plan zu kriegen. Wir haben ihn jetzt noch mal hier in der Leitung. Hallo Robin, zurück. Jetzt wollte Frank wissen, wie du das Smartphone nutzt, um dir weiterhelfen zu lassen oder um dir selbst zu helfen.
Also erstmal zur Nutzung allgemein vom iPhone. Das ist jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen schwer sich vorzustellen, wenn man sich damit noch nicht so beschäftigt hat, weil schlussendlich basiert das iPhone hauptsächlich auf dem Touchscreen und klar, dann kann man natürlich nicht ohne eine bestimmte Hilfe bedienen. Jetzt ist es aber zum Glück so, dass Apple eigentlich wirklich heutzutage die einzige große Mainstream Software-Firma ist und Computer-Hardware-Firma ist, die sich wirklich hingesetzt hat und gesagt hat, okay, wie können wir die ganzen Produkte, die wir haben, also jetzt wirklich so iPhone, iPod, auch die ganzen Mac Computer, wie können wir die bedienbar machen für Leute mit irgendwelchen Behinderungen, Einschränkungen, auch ohne vorher irgendwie verklagt worden zu sein, weil da gibt es ja auch viel was da irgendwie. Und auf jeden Fall gibt es seit ein paar Jahren auch schon für das iPhone, kriegen wir das für das iPhone 3GS, ein Programm, das nennt sich VoiceOver, ist standardmäßig auch im iOS mit integriert. Also man braucht es wirklich nur in der entsprechenden Einstellung einzuschalten. Und das geht dann über eine Schwachausgabe. Also sprich, ich fahre mit meinem Finger eben über das Display und bekomme eben vorgelesen, wo ich gerade drauf bin, kann das dann doppelt antippen, nicht einmal wie es normalerweise wäre, sondern doppelt. Und das wird dann zum Beispiel geöffnet, zum Beispiel eine App oder so, oder irgendwas in der Art. Und damit kann man eben eigentlich das iPhone so benutzen, wie jeder andere auch. Das ist halt vom Bedienkonzept her ein bisschen eine andere Sache, weil es halt entsprechend auf die Sprachausgabe und die nicht visuelle Bedienung angepasst wurde. Aber das geht wirklich problemlos. Also ich hab auch damals zum iPhone 3GS angefangen. Und manche Leute sagen mir, ich wär mit dem Ding sogar schneller als sie mittlerweile, obwohl sie da drauf schauen können. Also das ist wirklich eine super Sache. Und damit lässt du das iPhone eigentlich auch nahezu uneingeschränkt nutzen.
Und wofür benutzt du es denn tatsächlich? Also auch für irgendwie, um dich zurechtzufinden?
Ja, also es gibt viele Firmen, also zum Beispiel Enzo, in Nordrhein-Westfalen wird das im Moment. Da gibt es ein sehr großes Projekt, was auch vom Landesvermessungsamt sehr stark unterstützt und eigentlich auch initiiert worden ist. Und die sind wirklich hergegangen und haben sich überlegt, okay, wie kann man jetzt ein Gerät nutzen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel das iPhone, um zum Beispiel damit einen Menschen eine nahezu uneingeschränkte Navigation zu ermöglichen, sowohl in der Stadt als auch in Gebäuden. Da gibt es verschiedene Ansätze. Einiges davon passiert im Moment halt noch auf GPS. Wobei GPS ja mit seiner maximalen Genauigkeit von, ich glaube, irgendwie sieben oder zehn Metern oder so jetzt nicht so optimal ist dafür. Es gibt aber auch zum Beispiel sowas, dass man einen RFID-Laser im Schuh hat. Also theoretisch könnte man sich das wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie in den Fuß implantieren oder so was, wo man dann durch die Gegend läuft. Und am Boden sind dann, das ist hauptsächlich für Gebäudenavigationen, entwickelt worden. Am Boden sind dann eben so bestimmte Tags, die einen dann eben darüber informieren, bzw. sie das dann über den Laser weitergeben, an ein iPhone zum Beispiel, wo man sich gerade genau befindet. Und da wird also sehr viel eigentlich gemacht, auch jetzt dann sobald Galileo dann irgendwie mal am Start ist, was wahrscheinlich eher länger als kürzer dauern wird.
Das kann noch ein bisschen dauern, ja.
Ja, aber da sind auch schon wohl Empfänger in der Entwicklung, die dann auch, also die dann alles irgendwie verbinden, also sowohl GPS als auch, es gibt da glaube ich noch irgendwie ein russisches Navigationssystem.
Das heißt aber, das Telefon ist für dich denn sozusagen schon zu so einer Sinneserweiterung geworden in dem Sinne?
Ja, also es ist halt, also es kann natürlich, im Moment so wie es jetzt ist, hauptsächlich mit GPS, kann es natürlich nicht irgendwie, sagen wir mal, die Navigation mit einem Stock oder auch mit einem Blindenhund oder sowas zu setzen, aber es ist schon zu einer sehr, sehr großen Hilfe und ja schon auch eine Art Erweiterung geworden. Also ich wollte mir jetzt nicht unbedingt ein iPhone, ein Computer, sage ich mal, ins Hirn implantieren, aber ich finde, dass es wirklich eine super Sache ist und auch wirklich extrem, extrem hilft. Also da wird doch im Mainstream Bereich sehr viel gemacht. Zum Beispiel Navigon, was ja auch für Fußgängernavigation genutzt werden kann, ist auch für Blinde bedienbar. Wenn auch natürlich vom Material her nicht so exakt, wie man es halt gerne hätte, aber es funktioniert.
Eine kurze Frage noch Robin, das heißt, du würdest das iPhone, wenn das abhanden kommen würde, wenn man es abnehmen würde, würdest du auch sagen, dann fehlt dir tatsächlich etwas?
Also ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich ohne das Konzept aufgeschmissen wäre, aber klar, es würde natürlich schon was fehlen, klar, weil natürlich dann auch schon die Navigation zur nächsten Telefonzelle, wenn ich jetzt wirklich wo wäre, wo ich mich nicht auskenne, natürlich allein das schon schwierig werden würde. Wobei, da gibt es jetzt natürlich immer noch diese Menschen, die wieder bei rumlaufen.
Aber wenn du ein iPhone hast, brauchst du doch keine Telefonzelle, oder?
Ja, ne, das ist deshalb ja, wenn ich das iPhone weggenommen bekomme. Müsste ich ja irgendwie vielleicht Hilfe oder irgendwie das Ding anrufen zumindest. Wobei es gibt es auch, weil das auch so ein bisschen damit zu tun hat, es gibt auch Leute, gerade in Amerika, es gibt sowas, es nennt sich Extended 911, also das wenn man die 911 anwählt, da eben die Notfallstelle, dass man dann auch geortet werden kann, wenn man auf dem Handy aus anruft. Und es gibt tatsächlich in Amerika blinde Menschen, die sagen, wenn ich irgendwo auf der Straße verloren gehe, ruf ich da an und lasse mich orten, lasse mich dann von der Polizei einsammeln.
Das ist ein erweitertes Navigationssystem mit sozusagen auch noch emotionalen Fähigkeiten, nicht schlecht. Robin, dir vielen Dank für den Einblick in den Umgang mit noch externer Technik, die den Menschen erweitert. So, so unglaublich. Das finde ich sehr spannend. Ich hatte das vor dieser Sendung noch nicht, diesen Gedanken, dass man dann sagen konnte, okay, so das, was wir heutzutage benutzen, ist auch schon irgendwie ein Teil unseres Körpers.
Irgendwie, mein Gott, ohne das Mobiltelefon, was wir da ständig mit uns rumführen. Es ging ja irgendwie mit den armbandturen los. Das war da dann so ein präzises Zeitgefühl. Genau, hat uns geholfen so ein bisschen.
Na eigentlich kein Zeitgefühl. Eigentlich ist eine Uhr ja ein Synchronisationshilfsmittel. Also dass wir uns auf eine Zeit geeinigt haben und uns dieser synchronisierten Zeit gewahr werden. Ist ja keinen Sinn in dem Sinne.
Nee, es ist dann ein Sinn, wenn du einen Zeitraum abschätzt. Also wenn wir hier dauernd auf die Uhr gucken, wann es denn um halb ist, weil dann Nachrichten sind, dann ist das sehr wohl das Messen eines Zeitraumes. Also einer Zeitspanne von hier bis da.
Naja, aber wenn der Nachrichtensprecher nicht wüsste, dass es gleich halb ist, wäre es total egal. Deswegen ist es trotzdem nur eine Synchronisation.
Aber das Besondere dabei ist, dass man diese Uhr immer mit dabei hat. Sie war einfach um den Arm geschnallt und hattest du so deinen Augmented Time Sensor einfach immer mit dabei. Und irgendwann hatten Nerds irgendwie ihren Taschenrechner immer noch mit dabei. Und dann waren plötzlich ein Hygrometer, ein Barometer, ein Thermometer.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich finde diesen Unterschied schon interessant, weil die Uhr ist tatsächlich nur dann wichtig, wenn ich noch mit anderen Leuten zu tun habe. Also weil ich brauche eigentlich keine Uhr, wenn ich nur mit mir selbst unterwegs bin. Weil dann ist es halt echt egal, wie spät es ist.
Nö, also wenn es kalt wird.
Dazu kommt gerade der schöne Spruch, die Uhren sind die Trummler der Galerne der Neuzeit.
Aber man will vielleicht auch wissen, bevor es dunkel oder kalt wird, dass man dann irgendwie noch nach Hause zurückläuft. Das ist ja eine Tagessynchronisation. Dass du ungefähr weißt, wann Mittag ist, dass du ungefähr weißt, wie lange du gebraucht hast für irgendwas, dass ein Hinweg beim Wandern ungefähr genauso lange dauert wie ein Rückweg, ist schon wichtig.
Will ich aber trotzdem eine andere Kategorie packen als zum Beispiel ein Smartphone? Oder halt ein Computer?
Evolved halt.
Also interessant fand ich, ich hatte ja früher immer eine Uhr um den Arm, und zwar wegen der Sensor, nicht wegen der Uhr. Also mindestens ein Kompass musste schon sein, und eigentlich müsste es auch ein Barometer. Und das fand ich auch sehr nützlich. Und seit ich eben ein Smartphone habe, was all diese Funktionen quasi auch beinhaltet, habe ich halt keine Uhr mehr um, weil wozu auch? So, und eben die Menge an Daten und Informationen, die über so ein aktuelles Telefon verfügbar sind, also ich kann halt quasi in meinem Bett liegen, den Vorhang zulassen, auf meinem Telefon gucken, und ich weiß irgendwie, ob es da draußen regnet oder ob es gleich regnen wird.
Genau, ob es gleich regnen wird, das ist ja tatsächlich der.
Ich kann mit dem Regen gerade die Möglichkeit, das Wetter vorher zu sagen für mich persönlich, wo ich bin, ohne dass ich auch nur irgendwie aus dem Fenster gucken muss.
Ist schon krass, wie sich das gewandelt hat, dass am Ende in der Uhr der am wenigsten spannende Teil die Uhr selber ist und heute in den Telefon ist die langweiligste Abdehung, die ich auf meinem Telefon habe, ist diese blöde, das blöde Ding mit dem Hörer drauf, wo man nur eine eins zu eins Kommunikation mit irgendjemanden drehen kann, mit dem man sprechen muss.
Weil in Wirklichkeit verbindet mich dieses Smartphone ja mit meinem digital kollektiven Bewusstsein. Also mit meinen Freunden, mit Informationen aus dieser Welt da draußen, wo ich instantan erfahren kann, Dinge, die mich irgendwie womöglich betreffen oder zumindest emotional irgendwie tangieren. Und was der eine Anrufer vorhin meinte, naja natürlich, ich habe ja bereits ein Body Enhancement, das mir einen permanenten und unmittelbaren Zugriff auf Wikipedia ermöglicht. Ich kann ja auf das Weltwissen bereits zugreifen. Das heißt, diese ganzen heißen Debatten in den Kneipen, die sind heutzutage wahnsinnig kurz, da stellt sich irgendwie eine Frage und dann gucken drei Leute unterm Tisch nach. Wattet denn nun?
Man kann aber keine Scheiße mehr erzählen.
Und tun dann so, als hätten sie es selber gewusst.
Das ist wie auch für Politiker echt schwierig, weil wenn du nicht mit denen unterhältst und der erzählt dir irgendwas.
Fortgeschritten ist dann kurz vorher auf dem Klo noch die Wikipedia zu editieren, bevor man auf die Physik ist.
Wette gewonnen.
Aber das greift auch zu kurz einfach nur zu sagen, dass es einfach dein Sinnensorgan fürs Web ist. Weil da sind noch andere spannende Dinge dabei. Dein Mobiltelefon hilft dir auch Kram, was dein Kopf nicht so toll kann, wie zum Beispiel Bilder nehmen und sich merken, also präzise Bilder. Oder einfach Licht machen. Das war alles mit eingebaut. Da sind auch diverse andere Sensoren, wie gesagt der GPS-Sensor ist mit dabei. Du weißt, wo du bist. Du hast ein Recording Device, kannst dir da Gedanken entweder per Sprachnotiz oder per Notiz noch mit auf dein Mobiltelefon tun.
Ja, ist ein Gedächtnis schon auch. Ein Bildgedächtnis, ein Tongedächtnis und ein Informationsgedächtnis, durchaus.
Jetzt bringt das also sagen, wenn man das einen Schritt weiter denkt, eine spannende Frage auf. Nämlich jeder wäre sich, also eigentlich eine Hand darf man nicht abhauen. Also niemand, ich hab ein Recht auf meine Hände. Die darf man keiner wegnehmen.
Also da gab's Spiegelstrafen, Islam.
Wir reden jetzt hier Deutschland, so heute geteilt. Neuzeit Aufklärung, genau, Dankeschön. Würde ich dann auch sagen, quasi ein Smartphone, wenn man das so als Bodyenhancement beschreibt, ist ein Körperteil, wo man irgendwann sagen muss, das darf man eigentlich nicht mehr wegnehmen?
Ja, also wie sie sagen ja schon länger, also mindestens das Recht auf einen Computer und Internetanschluss mittlerweile wichtiger ist, als irgendwie das Recht auf einen Fernseher.
Ja, bei Weitem.
Bei Weitem, und dauert ja nun leider eine ganze Weile, bis sowas sich dann auch in dem allgemeinen Rechtsbewusstsein durchsetzt. Und bei Smartphones wird das in sehr kurzer absehbarer Zeit sehr ähnlich sein. Also das ist doch eine erhebliche Einschränkung ist, wenn man halt eben dieses Gerät weggenommen oder eingeschränkt bekommen kann.
Vor allem werden wir jetzt auch jede Menge Tools, externe Tools sehen, die an dieses Smartphone, das ich dann ja gar nicht mehr aus der Tasche nehmen muss, über Funk angebunden sind. Das Ding dann wie eine Zentrale agiert und mit Aktoren und Sensoren mich eben auch sozusagen in der Tasche über Dinge informiert. Oder dass zum Beispiel die Qualität meines Schlafes aufzeichnet über Sensoren in der Matratze zum Beispiel oder über Sensoren an meinem Handgelenk, die sehen, wie oft und wie viel ich mich bewege, über EKG oder EEG meine Schlafphasen messen kann.
Wenn du dann noch dein Telefon dazu bringen könntest, dass es dir langsam die Hormonausschüttung vorbereitet, bevor du aufstehen musst, dass es ein bisschen das Melatonin da abbaut schon in deinem Körper.
Bisschen das Licht hochfährt und ein bisschen Sonne, Vollspektrum Licht einschaltet und so weiter. Es gab einen Fall, da hat jemand sein Über auch über über ein Smartphone ab, über das nennt sich ja Quantified Self, kann man eine komplett eigene Sendung drüber machen, glaube ich. Das Beispiel nur, der hat halt seinen Puls immer aufgezeichnet und dann festgestellt, dass er auf dem Weg zur Arbeit an einer Stelle einen tierischen Puls hat und ist dann einfach mal einen anderen Weg gefahren. Das war halt irgendeine stressige Stelle an irgendeiner doofen Kreuzung. Dann ist er anders gefahren und seitdem fährt er mal völlig entspannt zur Arbeit. Ein bisschen weiter, aber viel entspannter. Das ist ja auch in gewissen Formen eine Art von Body Enhancement, sich sozusagen zu optimieren an solchen Stellen, den Schlaf zu optimieren, seine Nahrungsmittelaufnahme zu optimieren, deine Trainingsgewohnheiten, Sportgewohnheiten zu optimieren und auch den Erfolg davon zu prüfen, das Lungenvolumen zu testen, über einen Sensor beispielsweise, und dann zu gucken, ob bestimmte Maßnahmen erfolgreich sind und so weiter. Das ist auch in gewisser Form durch gezieltes Training mit digitaler Unterstützung auch Body Enhancement. Also letztlich ein Extra.
Jetzt finde ich es sehr spannend, dass wir die ganze Sendung über Body Enhancement reden, aber dass eigentlich all die Lösungen, die wir gehört haben, und auch, so habe ich zumindest das Gefühl, alle Lösungen, die ihr bevorzugen würdet, externe Lösungen sind. Das heißt also Sachen, die man sich anschnallt.
Das hat ja auch gute Gründe. Die sind einmal schon ganz kurz angeklungen. Next version will fix. Das heißt, wenn ich mir jetzt was einbauen lasse, was eine Operation verlangt, dann bin ich arschgekniffen, wenn es in einem Jahr das doppelt so geile Teil gibt. Dann muss ich mich entweder wieder operieren lassen, und by the way, auch das geht nicht beliebig oft. Das ist ja wie mit einem Gerät, das man dauernd öffnet, was eigentlich nicht dafür gedacht ist, geöffnet zu werden. Das wird ja nicht besser. Irgendwann ist die Nipsel ab. Und dann ist die Schraube weg. Das wird ja nicht besser, wenn man es dauernd ausmacht.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, wir sprechen dann gleich darüber, was das Problem ist, das Ding überhaupt anzuschließen, also diese Verbindung herzukriegen, zwischen Nerven und einem technischen Gerät, der nicht auf Kontakten basiert, sondern wirklich gewachsen ist. Und dann, warum das genau bei dem Operieren nicht beliebig oft funktioniert. Vorher aber sozusagen die Erweiterungen hier, die wir noch mitbekommen, zwangsweise das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Halbe Stunde haben wir noch im Chaos Radio, wo der Chaos Computer Club das Stuhl übernimmt, und wir sind noch mal im Monat. Heute sind Erdgeist, Jenny und Frank da. Hallo und willkommen zurück nochmal.
Hallo.
Und es geht heute darum, den menschlichen Körper durch Technik zu erweitern. Wir haben schon ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, was da so geht, was die Probleme sein könnten, was es heute schon für Technik gibt. Und dass vor allen Dingen Dinge, die wir ganz alltäglich benutzen, Smartphones zum Beispiel schon als eine Art Erweiterung unseres Körpers angesehen werden können. Und ich habe die erfreuliche Feststellung gemacht, dass die fleißigen Hörer während der Sendung ein sogenanntes Pad befüllt haben, wo man die ganze Sendung wirklich nachlesen kann. Also alle Punkte, die man, die in dieser Sendung schon aufgegriffen wurden, sind ernotiert. Und den genauen Link findet ihr im Wiki zur Sendung unter chaosradio.de. So, letzte halbe Stunde wollen wir nochmal füllen mit zumindest einem Problem, das wir haben, nämlich wie die Verbindung zwischen Technik und menschlichem Körper genau gemacht werden kann. Ihr könnt noch anrufen, wenn ihr wollt uns mal erklären, was ihr euch einbauen lassen würdet und wo ihr denkt, naja, das sollte man lieber vielleicht nicht machen. So, wir haben jetzt die letzte halbe Stunde damit abgeschlossen, dass es hieß, okay, das ist alles extern und operieren ist eigentlich nicht so richtig geil, weil dann gibt es irgendwie eine neue Version. Das heißt, das grundlegende Problem ist, es gibt noch keine Schnittstelle, die wirklich so gut ist, dass sie ganz genau alle Nerven abgreift. Warum nicht? Was ist da das Problem?
Na ja, es kommt drauf an, wie man das meint. Also so ein Bildschirm ist schon auch eine Mensch-Maschine-Schnittstelle, die eine immens große Bandbreite hat, nur mal als Beispiel. Jetzt könnte man sagen, okay, ich habe jetzt eine optische Verbindung zwischen dem Computer und meinem Hirn hergestellt. Die ist wirklich wahnsinnig breitbandig. Wenn ich jetzt die gleiche Verbindung über die Nerven direkt ohne den Umweg über die Optik herstellen wollte, müsste ich ja jeden dieser einzelnen Nervenbahnen irgendwie mit einem Chip verbinden. Das ist einfach mal nicht trivial und das ist auch eben sehr invasiv. Ja, also dazu muss man das Auge aufmachen und dazu muss man da drin rum basteln. Und dabei kann natürlich auch viel schiefgehen. Wir alle haben schon mal gehört von multiresistenten Keimen und so weiter. Also ich kenne Menge Leute, die im Medizingewerber arbeiten und die alle sagen, ey, nicht ins Krankenhaus, wenn du nicht musst. Und die wissen, warum sie das sagen. Und sowas freiwillig zu machen, nur um seine Funktionalität zu erweitern, sich dem Risiko auszusetzen, irgendeine Infektion zu kriegen oder irgendeine Komplikation zu kriegen, das ist schon eine echte Hürde. Zumal wenn es gute Alternativen gibt. Also wenn man tatsächlich nicht gehandicapt ist, dann kann ich mir vorstellen, so eine Erweiterung, die ich gerne hätte, ich würde gerne in anderen Frequenzbändern sehen können. Ich würde gerne im Infrarotbereich sehen können. Ich würde gerne im Terraherzbereich sehen können.
Dann müsste ich mir für dich aber noch andere Unterwäsche anziehen.
Keine Details bitte.
So genau wollten wir das nicht wissen. Aber das kann man ja erreichen, indem man eine Brille baut mit einem Bildschirm drauf, die mir sowohl das Live-Bild zeigt, als auch Bilder in anderen Spektren überlagert beispielsweise. Also Google hat gerade vorgestellt, so ein Projekt, wo sie eben eine Augmented Reality-Brille bauen wollen, anbieten wollen. Das ist ja so ein erster Schritt in die Richtung. Alle, die den großartigen Roman von Daniel Suarez, Demon und Darknet gelesen haben, die wissen auch, um welche Brille es da geht.
Unbedingt Leseempfehlung?
Unbedingt Leseempfehlung, jawohl. Da geht es ja letztlich auch in einem Body Enhancement. Was ich mir eben auch wünschen würde, wäre, wenn irgendwas in Kollisionskurs mit mir ist, dass ich eine Warnung kriege. Also wenn irgendwas, was Groß und Schnelles auf mich zukommt und mich treffen wird, wenn ich nichts unternehme.
Selbst wenn ich es noch nicht sehe. Exoskelett, die ich einfach gleich zusammenzogen lassen.
Solche Sachen gibt es ja schon. Zumindest Exo-Mente halber. Also quasi das Weiterdenken von dem Kompassgürtel, von dem Erdgasthorn erzählt hat. Was wieder mal beim Militär entwickelt wurde, nämlich zum Beispiel Westen, die man unter den Fliegeranzug zieht und die einen durch so kleine Pikse an der richtigen Stelle warnen, aus welcher Richtung gerade der Feind kommt. Also klar ist, wir haben noch eine Menge Sensoren an unserer Hautoberfläche zum Beispiel, mit denen man noch experimentieren kann, wo man sich halt einfach noch Sachen ausdenken kann. Wie wir vorhin schon erzählt haben, ist das Hirn in überraschender Weise in der Lage, Sensorimpulse bestimmt einer eigenen gewohnheitsmäßig zuzuordnen. Und dementsprechend kann man dieses mit ein bisschen Training eben auch benutzen. Also wenn man sich anguckt, wie zum Beispiel, was wir vorhin erzählt hatten, die Sache mit der Armprothese, wo man sagt, man braucht drei bis zwölf Monate Training, aber danach kann man andere Nerven benutzen für Sachen, wofür sie ursprünglich nicht vorgesehen waren. Und so ähnlich ist es eben auch mit den Nerven zum Beispiel in der Hautüberfläche, die man für solche Dinge auch benutzen kann. Und man genau diese Übersetzung von Sinnen in andere Sinne finde ich sehr spannend. Es gibt zum Beispiel auch Projekte, um für blinde Menschen die Geometrie eines Raumes in dreidimensional zu erfassen und in Akustik umzusetzen. Es gibt halt Blinde, die machen sowas selber, indem sie so Schnallzlaute machen mit der Zunge, also Klapp, Klapp, Klapp, Laute, und aus den Reflektionen im Raum sich selber ein Bild bauen. So wie Fledermäuse quasi. Genau. Und sowas gibt es dann auch in Technik, also dass man halt einfach einen 3D-Bild zum Beispiel mit sowas wie einer Kinect erfasst, von dem Raum, und das dann wiederum in Akustik umsetzt. Also dass man halt Geräusche von Gegenständen, die näher kommen oder so erzeugt. Und diese Fähigkeit des menschlichen Körpers, Sinne A, höher aufgelöst zu benutzen, und B, auch so zu benutzen, wie sie überhaupt nicht vorgesehen sind oder wie sie die Evolution bisher noch nicht gemacht hat, die ist extrem spannend. Da gibt es halt noch so viele Möglichkeiten, dass man noch eine Menge Platz hat, bevor man dann irgendwie mit dem Skype heran muss.
Genau das ist der Punkt. Solange es noch andere Optionen gibt, würde man das ja nicht machen wollen. Auch der Gürtel von Erdgeist vorhin, der ist ja auch so ein Beispiel. Man könnte den natürlich jetzt mit mehr Vibratoren ausstatten, mehrzeilig sozusagen und auch nicht nur acht, sondern sagen wir mal 32 rundum. Und dann kann man schon ein sehr subtiles Bild von Dingen, die im Weg stehen, durch entsprechende Vibrationen an diesen Stellen symbolisieren. Oder einen Weg. Ich habe einfach eine Route berechnet. Palm hat auf so etwas ein Patent, habe ich gerade gestern gesehen, bei der Recherche zur Sendung. Ein Patent darauf, dass man in einem Smart Device eine Route rechnet und genauso eine Art Aktorgürtel, Vibratorgürtel, einem jetzt den Weg entlang der Route zeigt. Das heißt, ich laufe gerade aus und irgendwann geht die Vibrationsrichtung nach rechts und dann weiß ich, ich drehe mich so lange nach rechts, bis die Vibration wieder vorne ist und fixiere damit sozusagen meinen nächsten Wegpunkt. Und somit kann man sich quasi, ohne dass man auf irgendwo rauf gucken muss, ohne dass man beim Autofahren abgelenkt wird, erfahren, an der nächsten Kreuzung muss ich rechts abbiegen, dann muss ich so und so lang geradeaus fahren und dann muss ich langsam links abbiegen oder auch zu Fuß, ohne irgendwas anzuschauen und ohne mich ablenken zu lassen. Man kann sich dabei vermutlich unterhalten, man kann dabei vermutlich beliebiger andere Dinge tun und wird trotzdem intuitiv wissen, wo man lang muss.
Und der Hack wäre dann diese Route zu hacken und jemand woanders hinzuschicken. Jetzt sind diese, also wie gesagt, ihr wollt es lieber nicht invasiv, das sind aber alles sehr praktisch pragmatische Überlegungen, um nochmal auf diese Wünsch dir was Sache zurückzukommen. Ich würde sagen, das Ende der Fahnschlange wäre der Cyborg-Körper mit einem Gehirn drin.
Am besten mit meinem Gehirn drin, ja.
Die Vision dahinter ist ja das Brain-Computer-Interface. Also das BCI, da gibt es Ansätze, ich hab so was auch schon mal ausprobiert, da wird halt ein EEG genommen, jetzt noch mit Kontakten auf der Kopfoberfläche. Die Idee dahinter ist, dass Aktivität im Hirn sozusagen Potentialdifferenzen erzeugt, die sich bis auf die Kopfoberfläche fortpflanzen und man die mit EEG-Sensorik, also hoch empfindlicher elektromagnetischer Sensorik, abgreifen kann. Und darüber eben bestimmte Muster feststellen kann, die erzeugt werden, wenn man beispielsweise die Hand bewegt. Ich hab das seinerzeit, das ist schon ewig her, das muss heute schon viel, viel besser sein, ausprobiert. Da musste man eben, was weiß ich, ein paar tausend Mal eine Maus bewegen. Und das System hat dabei gelernt, wie mein Hirnstrommuster aussieht, während ich diese Maus bewege. Und irgendwann konnte man die Maus weglegen und nur noch denken, dass man diese Maus bewegt. Und dieser Maus-Cursor bewegte sich dann also in diese Richtung. Das war nicht perfekt, das war noch sehr holprig, aber das ist auch schon zehn Jahre her. Also das muss heute schon sehr viel besser gehen. Das ist natürlich eine Form von Brain-Computer-Interface, die sich, wenn man nicht die Schädeldecke dazwischen hat, sehr, sehr, sehr viel besser ginge. Wenn man also tatsächlich jetzt Elektronen an bestimmte Stellen im Hirn implantiert und diese Informationen dann über eine Schnittstelle nach draußen gibt, kann man sehr, sehr, sehr viel präziser ermitteln, was der Mensch da gerade denkt. Das geht ja so weit, dass man heute über Sampling von immens vielen Bildern, also man zeigt Leuten Bilder und nimmt dabei ein Kernspintomogramm ihrer Gehirnaktivität auf. Und wenn man das ein paar Tausend Mal gemacht hat, können die Leute an andere Bilder denken, an beliebige andere Bilder oder auch zum Beispiel was träumen. Und der Computer errechnet, wie ungefähr dieses Bild so grob aussieht, dass man gerade denkt, aufgrund der Beispiele, die man vorher gegeben hat, indem man Bilder angeschaut hat.
Und geht es dann sozusagen auch umgedreht, also so wie in Strange Days, dass man quasi im Hirn Bilder erzeugt und so den Leuten Filme zeigt, ohne dass man...
Naja, also wie gesagt, das nächste, wo man da momentan dran ist, ist halt diese transkranierende Magnetstimulation. Aber da sind... Da ist die Technik noch nicht so weit, dass man da richtig ins Hirn reinrennen kann.
Man müsste da hochpräzise an bestimmte Stellen explizit ganz genaue Impulse geben. Ich glaube, die Richtung rein ist sehr viel schwieriger über eine Elektronik als raus. Also rein, da eignen sich eher die Sensoren, die man eh schon hat, die auch breitbandig angebunden sind, wie Tastsinne auf Zunge, Finger, wie Gehör, wie Optik eben und so weiter. Aber raus, ich glaube, da wäre es schon sinnvoll, sich direkt an die Nerven anzudocken.
Und gibt es nicht, wenn diese ganzen Enhancements, von denen wir jetzt die ganze Zeit geredet haben, wenn die kommen, gibt es dann nicht auch die Gefahr, dass wir eine Zweiklassengesellschaft kriegen? Weil heutzutage, also Smartphones und Internetzugang sind tatsächlich in einen Bereich angekommen, wo es zumindest theoretisch denkbar ist, das hat jeder, zumindest hier in Deutschland. Aber so Enhancements, die dann hochtechnisch sind?
Das hat nicht jeder, also auch Smartphones sind jetzt schon nicht bei jedem verfügbar. Es gibt irgendwie auch gerade auch Zweiklassengesellschaft bei den älteren Menschen, die damit den Smartphones gar nicht klarkommen. Aber was ich vorhin ja extra gefragt hatte, war, ob die Krankenkasse diese Implantate oder diese Prothesen übernimmt. Ist halt die Frage, ob irgendwann, wenn bestimmte Körperteile einfach wegen Altersschwäche ausfallen würden, ob man dann überhaupt noch eines natürlichen Todes sterben würde oder ob die Gesellschaft dann dafür aufkommen muss, dass älteren Menschen dann nacheinander alle ausfallenden Organe ersetzt werden. Und wie es dann aussieht, wer es bezahlen soll, ob man da im Vorfeld eine spezielle Versicherung dazu kaufen muss und ob man dazu besonders reich sein muss, damit Leber, Milz, Lunge, keine Ahnung, was wichtig ist, Alter ersetzt wird.
Also die am meisten verwendete Prothese sind der Zahnimplantate. Und die werden von der Krankenkasse ja schon nicht mehr vollständig gedeckt. Also wenn man tatsächlich den State of the Art haben will, das heißt also halt irgendwie eine poröse Titanschraube in den Kiefer, auf der dann oben halt irgendwie ein custom gebasteltes Keramikimplantat drauf sitzt, ist nichts, was die Krankenkasse halt vollständig bezahlt, sondern da muss man halt selber ran. Das heißt, wir haben also diese, diese Zwei-Klassen-Gesellschaft bildet sich da sowieso schon langsam heraus, eben an den Stellen, wo es am meisten kostet oder eben zu teuer ist und vor allen Dingen in hohen Zahlen auftritt. Also zum Beispiel so eine Beinprothese oder eine Armprothese, die wird halt sehr viel seltener verwendet als eben zum Beispiel so ein Zahnimplantat, was halt millionenfach implantiert wird. Und dementsprechend verschieben sich dann natürlich einfach klar die Dinge dahin, dass also Menschen, die mehr Geld haben, im Zweifel halt die bessere Technologie bekommen. Und in dem Augenblick, wo es halt dahin geht, dass die Implantate eben nicht mehr medizinisch notwendig, also im Sinne einer Restoration von ohnehin vorhandenen Fähigkeiten sind, sondern ja mehr oder minder optionaler Luxus werden, da wird es wahrscheinlich dann eben noch eine Mehrklassengesellschaft geben, also die halt auch dahin geht zum Beispiel, ob man bestimmte Jobs ohne bestimmte Implantate schlicht nicht bekommen kann, weil man sie halt nicht ausfüllen kann, weil man nicht den Anforderungen entspricht oder bestimmte Schnittstellen schlicht nicht hat, die halt zum Beispiel für die Bedienung von komplexen Maschinen notwendig sind.
Das wird mit Sicherheit wieder beim Militär anfangen, die ja auch am intensivsten schon sozusagen im Live-System Brain Computer Interfaces und eben andere Body Enhancements nutzt. Also mitunter ist in diesen Jets schon das Auswählen von Zielen beziehungsweise das Auslösen des Abschusses über ein Brain Computer Interface gelöst, einfach um die Reaktionszeit zu verkürzen in dem Moment. Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass in kurzer Zeit, also in einer Größenordnung einstellige Jahreszahlen, es notwendig werden könnte, wenn nicht sowieso alles in Richtung, komplett in Richtung Drohnen geht, aber dann betrifft es halt den Drohnenoperator, dass er eine Schnittstelle sich implantieren lassen muss, wenn er diesen Job machen will, damit er schnell genug reagieren kann, schnell genug die Entscheidungen auch in einer Handlung übersetzen kann, ohne darüber über irgendeine Motorik gehen zu müssen.
Wenn man das weiterdenkt, dann kommst du bei der Straßenverkehrsordnung raus, dass du am Ende vielleicht dein eigenes Auto nur noch steuern darfst, wenn du solche Interfaces in deinem Gehirn implementiert hast.
Denke mal, dass der, also realistisch betrachtet, wird es nicht an solchen Stellen sein, weil, also wie gesagt bei Flugzeugen werden es halt die Drohnen, die werden ohnehin autonomer und Autos fahren sowieso schon von selber. Also, dass der Mensch da zwingend notwendig ist, ist halt irgendwie ja nicht bewiesen und belegt im Gegenteil.
Tolle Autos, blöderweise sitzen da Menschen drin, ja.
Ja, die sind halt eigentlich nur dafür da, irgendwie Menschen durch die Gegend zu fahren.
Das ist ja auch ein cooles Body Enhancement. Ja, ein Exoskelett, erster Güte. Das ist sogar...
Vier-Räderiges Exoskelett, total super.
Der weiß ja sogar, wie weit was weg ist und so, ist ja super.
Ja, meins ist zweiräderig.
Markus Exoskelett liegt ja besonders eng an, wenn wir alle drin sitzen.
Weil ihr so gut genährt seid. Okay, anderes Thema. Ich würde gerne am Ende von euch noch mal wissen, wie ihr, wenn ihr in die Glaskugel guckt, so die nächsten Jahre seht. Und jetzt also unabhängig von den Problemen, die es damit gibt, die wir gerade beschrieben haben, was die Entwicklungen sind, auf die ihr euch freut. Wo ihr aber auch denkt, die sind tatsächlich auch realisierbar.
Ich fand ja die Quadrocopter-Entwicklung total toll, weil ich so ein bisschen gedacht hab, man könne sich irgendwann reinsetzen und damit dann ziemlich präzise durch die Gegend fahren. Aber es gibt andere ähnliche Entwicklungen. Es gibt da den Schweizer Piloten, der sich da so ein Jetpack auf dem Rücken draufgesetzt hat, aus seinem Flugzeug rausspringt und dann mit so kleinen Stummelflügeln hinten dran, da einfach ganz natürlich damit durch die Gegend fliegt und dann noch mit Falschum landet. Aber wenn sowas irgendwann mal, man geht aus der Tür raus und kann so senkrecht starten, fliegt der hin, wo man hin möchte.
Also du willst doch eigentlich nur deinen Flying Car haben, oder?
Nee, warum Car? Car ist irgendwie auch so eine Krücke. Eigentlich will ich ganz nah dran. Vogelflug ist natürlich der uralte Traum, aber...
Ich will so ein Exoskelett mit zwei großen Flügeln dran. Und dann schwingst du die Schwingen und hebst dich halt in die Lüfte und spürst dann die Thermik im kleinen Finger.
Und es muss blau sein.
Nein, ganz realistisch denke ich, wir werden eine Menge sehen in dem Bereich Augmented Reality. Also Dinge, die ich in mein live visuelles Bild eingeblendet bekomme. Also eine Brille, die mir Informationen einblendet, während ich durchgucke oder eben Smartphones, die ich irgendwo hinhalte in Richtung eines Gebäudes auf dem Fenster und dann sagt er mir, was dahinter ist oder in welche Richtung ich gehen muss, wenn ich da und da hin will. Wir werden mehr solche Dinge sehen, wie der Gürtel, den Erdgeist beschrieben hat, in manchfaltiger Form. Das ist ja nicht der einzige Weg, so was zu machen über Vibrationsmotörchen. Da gibt es ja Tausende Wege, elektrisch stimulieren, etc. thermisch stimulieren. Aber ich glaube, die meisten dieser Aspekte werden erst mal extern bleiben. Sicherlich, und da hoffe ich, dass es soweit ist, bis wir 20, 30 Jahre älter sind, das Exoskelett für die älteren Leute. Also mit einem Rollator zu all die Schieben. Ich glaube, das wär nicht mein Traum. Ich würde dann schon gerne so ein Ding haben, dass mich da halt agil hinläuft.
Und wie vielstens drei Meter hoch ist und irgendwie fünfmal so stark, wie du heute bist.
Nee, ich mein, aber das ist genau der Punkt. In dem Moment, wo so Body Enhancements, also eigentlich Prothesen, besser sind als das Original. In dem Moment wollen das normale Menschen auch. Also wenn Blinde jetzt eine Technologie kriegen, mit der sie nicht nur sich perfekt orientieren können, sondern auch noch sehen, was hinter ihnen ist und auch noch sehen, wenn da Autos um die Ecke kommen, die sie noch gar nicht zu sehen sind, spätestens dann finden andere Leute, das hätten sie auch ganz gerne. Ja, also ist immer die Frage. Hörgeräte, das hatten wir vorhin schon. Wenn jemand, der schwerhörig ist, plötzlich mehr Möglichkeiten hat als jemand, der normal hört. Oder jemand, der Brillenträger ist, plötzlich deutlich besser sehen kann als jemand, der normalsichtig ist. In dem Moment überlegt sich der Normalsichtig, denn dem brauch ich jetzt nicht auch eine Brille.
Das ist heute mit Augengläsern ja schon, dass du nicht über 120 Prozent nach Lasik da so an Sehkraft rausbekommst.
Weil es eben aber auch wieder degeneriert. Und dann am Ende doch wieder bei 100 Prozent oder weniger.
Ja, aber ist ja wurscht. Ich meine, letztlich, was momentan noch fehlt, ist eine Brille, die sich automatisch in ihrer Brennweite an die Brennweite meines Auges adaptiert. Die einfach ein bisschen stärker das tut, was mein Auge versucht zu tun, aber nicht mehr so recht kann. Und mir dann eben die Brille lernt, dass ich jetzt hier makro will. Ich gucke ganz dicht irgendwo ran, und das heißt, sie funktioniert jetzt wie eine Lupe. Und fokussiert ganz stark auf diesen Bereich. Und wenn ich in die Entfernung gucke, naja, dann stellt sie halt auf Entfernung scharf. Das gibt einen größeren Range. Das werden wir sehen in den nächsten 10, 15, 10 Jahren. Doch in 10 gibt es das. In 10 Jahren werden Leute, die es schlechter sehen, als wir heute besser sehen, als die, die heute gut sehen.
Frank, hast du auch noch einen speziellen Wunsch?
Naja, also ich denke, dass die Entwicklung natürlich da hingehen wird, den menschlichen Körper zumindest zu erhalten und so moderat aufzubessern. Aber ich hätte tatsächlich gerne Augmented Reality Erweiterungen schon sehr gern. Also Dinge, mit denen man halt einfach seine Umgebung besser wahrnehmen kann, sich besser erinnern kann, sich im Zweifel besser orientieren kann. Und die sind ja auch relativ nahe dran. Und ansonsten hätte ich gerne einfach ein 3 Meter hohes Exoskelett.
Mit Laserkanonen?
Ja, mit Laserkanonen und Raketenwerfern.
Zu viel Avatar geguckt.
Nee, um zu Aldi zu gehen.
Da passt du nicht durch die Tür.
Dann schon.
Diese Entwicklung der Exoskelette, es gibt ja auch so, Justarte Frank mir neulich erst erzählt, so Exoskelette, die schon noch eher ein gewebtes Material sind, die kontrahieren können, die man sich nicht mehr spossen kann.
Genau, es ist so eine Entwicklung, das ist auch so ein DAPA Projekt. Was sie tun, ist so eine Art dicken Taucheranzug bauen. Das ist halt so ein neoprenatiges Material, in dem künstliche Muskelfasern drin sind, die elektrisch betrieben werden. Und Sensorik dazu, sodass man, wenn man sich stößt, also wenn sozusagen das Material merkt, man hat einen Impact an irgendeiner Stelle, dann wird es halt hart an dieser Stelle. Und Schritt zwei ist, dass man sich, dass dieses Ding einen bewegen kann. Also dass es halt eine quasi überall verteilte, dünne zusätzliche Muskelschicht gibt, die aber stärker ist als der Mensch darunter. Und man eben nicht mehr das Problem hat, dass man so ein Exoskelett irgendwo festschnallen muss oder sich da dransetzen, reinsetzen muss und irgendwie dann die üblichen Probleme mit Druck stellen und irgendwie sowas hat, sondern das halt einfach eine quasi sozusagen eine zweite Haut ist, die einen bewegen kann. Also da gibt es noch eine Menge mehr Ansätze als so, sag mal, so Mechwarrior-Style.
Das ist mir persönlich auch sympatisch, also eine kleine Jacke, die mich noch ein bisschen stärker macht.
Muss man nur aufpassen, wenn diese Jacke dann irgendwann unkontrolliert anfängt zu kontrahieren, dann kannst du dir wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich schnell den Arm brechen. Da ist dann Softwarequalität schon echt toll.
Gut, hoffen wir mal, dass sie sozusagen von einer firten Firma geschrieben wird. Ich möchte jetzt ganz zum Schluss, weil das Chaos Radio ist gleich zu Ende, noch eine Frage erstellen. Und zwar habt ihr von diesem Gürtel jetzt mehrfach erzählt, der einem die Richtung angibt. Und ihr habt auch erzählt, dass er eigentlich seit anderthalb Jahren verpeilt, das Ding mal zu bauen. Wie schwierig ist das denn?
Gar nicht. Gar nicht schwierig. Man muss es jetzt nur endlich mal wieder machen.
Es gab doch halt am Ende nur so ein Detailproblem, dass der Kompassstein, den ich mir abkommen lassen, mit dem Mikrocontroller nicht sprechen wollte.
Ich kann es kurz erläutern, wie man so was machen würde. Es gibt Motorcontroller für diese Vibrationsmotoren. Das Problem ist, entweder macht man sie nur an und aus. Das ist aber nicht cool. Man will auch ein bestimmtes Vibrationsmuster erzeugen. Dafür braucht man eine H-Brücke, also eine Schaltung, mit der man den Motor vorwärts als auch rückwärts drehen lassen kann. Wobei die Richtung nicht so wichtig ist. Viel wichtiger ist, dass wenn man ihn jetzt mit Kraft angemacht hat, man ihn auch mit Kraft wieder bremsen kann, damit man einen gezielten Impuls, einen Vibrationsimpuls erzeugen kann. Und das auch in einer bestimmten Frequenz, sodass man über die Änderung der Vibrationsfrequenz und über die Vibrationsstärke noch mal unterschiedliche Aussage machen kann. Und die will man jetzt ansteuern über einen Mikrocontroller, beispielsweise einen Arduino. Also ein Arduino, das ist eigentlich so ein Elektronik-Open-Source-Projekt, eigentlich eine C-Library für Atmel Mikrocontroller.
Also Leute, die Ahnung haben, wissen jetzt schon, wovon du redest und denken sich wahrscheinlich, okay, das kann noch nicht so schwer sein.
Das ist nicht schwer.
Gibt es denn irgendwo einen Link, den man klicken kann? Gibt es eine Bauanleitung für das Ding quasi?
Es gibt eine. Jetzt hab ich den Link vergessen.
So, Hausaufgabe für die anwesenden Leute im Chaosradio ist. Bitte den Link von den Gürteln noch mal raussuchen. Es gibt ein Pad zur Sendung, wo die Hörer ganz fleißig alles zusammengetragen haben, was hier in dieser Sendung gesagt wurde. Link dazu auf Chaosradio.de. So, Famous Last Words. Will die einer noch sagen oder sind wir eigentlich durch?
I want my flying car.
Auch am Ende des Menschen, Maschinen, Maschinen, Menschen, Chaosradios, ist das der große Wunsch. Erdgeist Steini und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club Warnier haben erzählt, wie das so gehen kann mit der Menschenmaschine und den Maschinenmenschen. Vielen Dank dafür.
Gerne.
Es gibt in circa einer Stunde oder zwei vielleicht auf Fritz.de den Podcast zur Sendung. Dann könnt ihr euch die ganze Sendung nochmal nachhören. Dann auch demnächst auf Chaosradio.de. Hier gibt es jetzt auch gleich einen Track von Trekkie Birthday, der Website heißt und die wir immer spielen. Nach mir kommt Henrik Schröder und bewirft euch mit Punkmusik in eure akustischen Extremitäten. Und mir bleibt dann eigentlich nur noch eins zu sagen. Und das ist, mein Name ist Marcs Richter. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und macht immer schön eure Backups.